today i'm going to be speaking with uh
mark robert rank who is professor of
social welfare
at washington university in st louis and
also
author of the book poorly understood
uh out now by oxford university press
so great to have you on today oh thanks
david great to be with you
so i mean let's just jump into maybe
what's one of the meatiest
uh uh diving boards into this topic
maybe which
which are the misunderstandings about uh
the poor
in the united states two of which
correct me if i'm wrong
are the misunderstanding that most poor
people don't work
and the misunderstanding that most poor
people are
minorities ethnically or or racially
tell us maybe
how this came about but also the truth
of the statistics
yeah i think you know kind of underlying
those myths
is the idea that uh or the myth that you
know poverty
happens to somebody else it doesn't
happen to me and so
you know it happens to folks who don't
work or folks that are
minorities um but you know it doesn't
really affect me
it's not going to happen to me and what
we show in the book
is that actually uh if you look at the
majori
the majority of folks in poverty are
actually white um a majority
of or more folks in poverty live in
suburban areas than in central cities
and some of the deepest seated poverty
is in rural america
and the idea that the poor don't work is
simply wrong
most of the poor have have worked in the
past and will work in the future
and it's it's really important to think
about poverty as something that people
go
through they're not poor their whole
lives
they hit a spell where they have some
tough times they experience poverty they
may be out of work
but then they get back on their feet and
they will work in the future
so you know i think underlying those
ideas is this
myth that you know poverty is something
that
happens to somebody else and doesn't
happen to me
uh there's a few different things i
think would be interesting to explore
you mentioned
suburban versus urban is there
how can we quantify and qualify the
difference between the rural and
suburban poverty
versus the urban poverty which maybe is
more the caricature of where the myths
come from yeah so if you um
you know it's certainly the case that
folks in you know
inner city central city areas um the
poverty rates
are higher than the overall rate
but there's many more folks now that
live
outside of central cities and so in
terms of the number of folks in poverty
you know again it's higher in uh
surrounding urban areas as opposed to
the central city and as i mentioned
if you look at some of the most extreme
poverty in the united states it's
actually found in rural america
so areas like appalachia the deep south
and mississippi delta american indian
reservations the central corridor of
california all those areas have really
really deep-seated poverty
and that's kind of you know when we we
have this image of
of who are the poor we often think about
the poor as
you know non-whites in inner city areas
and it's not to discount that that
poverty exists there of course
but poverty is much much wider the way i
like to describe it is that
the reach of poverty is really wide but
its grip
is is not that strong people move in and
out of poverty a lot
what are the most common reasons that
people
who at some point were not poor end up
in poverty which maybe is different from
transgenerational poverty where you're
you're born into poverty and remain
there
is there an interesting distinction to
be made there there is
so um the folks that are um
long term in poverty is about 10 to 15
of everybody who will experience poverty
so about 85
of people who experience poverty do so
for a fairly short period of time and by
short i mean
a year or two now why do they experience
poverty
it's because things happen to people
that they didn't anticipate like
losing a job a family splitting up
getting sick
a pandemic occurring all of these things
have the potential
to throw people into poverty for a short
period fairly short period of time
now what's interesting about this is
i've done a lot of work in the and the
book focuses on this right from the
get-go
of the question of what's the long-term
likelihood that an american at some
point will experience poverty right
it turns out that between the ages of 20
and 75
60 percent of americans will experience
one year below the official
poverty line and three quarters will
experience poverty or near poverty
and the reason is because again over a
long period of time things happen to
people
that can throw them into poverty and
when that happens there's not a lot
in place to protect them how how much or
is that number
at all skewed to um people in their
very early 20s in college who
are technically in poverty but it's not
really reflective of their situation
yeah that's a great that's a great
question and that that's a question that
we
we often get on that research and so
what we did is we took out
um those folks and we did the analysis
and found that it it
it varied um it didn't change very much
i mean the number of people that are
actually in graduate school you know
that might sort of fit that sort of
starving student
picture um is actually pretty small and
so it doesn't really affect the numbers
very much at all
graduate school and presumably college
uh juniors and seniors right i mean 20
20 years
yeah it's so it's rel it's not a huge
doesn't change the numbers dramatically
it doesn't change that when you
again when you look over a 30 or 40 year
period it really doesn't change it very
much
when it comes to the i mean i i
it may go back before this actually
maybe that's a good good question
for me some of the big historical
markers
of when the narrative around the poor
started to resemble what it is now i
think back to
the reagan era the story of you know the
welfare taking cadillac
queen having kids in order to get food
stamps and
uh how how far back does that trope sort
of go
well i think you're right that that kind
of the modern version of that really
started with ronald reagan but the idea
of the deserving and the undeserving
poor actually goes back
400 years to sort of england's poor laws
at the time
but certainly ronald reagan was the one
in in more modern times that really
emphasized that
and the argument that he's making was
making
was using those stereotypes to argue
for smaller government you know his big
line one of his lines was
you know government is not the the
answer government is the problem
that we fought a war on poverty and
poverty won well
it turns out that well-constructed
government programs
actually have a very significant effect
on reducing poverty
so take the war on poverty in 1959
the poverty rate in the united states
was around 22 percent by 1973 it was 11
we cut poverty in half because of the
war on poverty and because of the strong
economic growth during that time
so did we eliminate poverty no but it's
an example that government actually can
be
quite effective in reducing poverty so
in
terms of reducing poverty i mean the the
you there are some
uh poverty inducing factors that are
similar around the world and there are
some
that are that are less common you know
medical expense bankruptcy
doesn't exist in many countries it does
exist in the united states so this this
understanding that this may be hard to
parse out when we talk about poverty
discussions often include all of the
following and more
minimum wage access to health care
improving education cost of living
rising wage gap uh on and on and on
what interventions have been shown to be
the most effective at cutting poverty
well i think the number one
number one solution is
jobs that can pay a decent wage jobs
that provide a livable wage and also
having benefits associated with those so
what has happened in the united states
over the last 40 or 50 years
is we've been producing more and more
low-wage jobs
and jobs that don't provide benefits and
so
a median male worker who is full-time in
the labor market
today is earning slightly less once you
control for inflation
than he was earning in 1973. there's
been a huge stagnation
and that's one of the reasons why more
and more people are at risk of poverty
because they're working at jobs that
just can't support a family
so i think that's the number one factor
that we need to focus on but as you
point out there are many
other factors as well such as you know
having access to health care
child care good education those are all
really key elements to
addressing the issue of poverty when we
think about
um stimulus like the kind we've seen now
three times during the course of the
pandemic
or a proposal for a 15 minimum wage
which the sort of more
free-market-minded folks would say
these are these are artificial um
decisions that are being imposed the
minimum wage would be a price
floor on labor that might be above what
the market would dictate or just
dumping a one-time payment on people is
not really going to systemically change
the value of their work to an employer
or whatever the case may be
what do we know about the longer term
impact of those types of interventions
yeah interesting so first of all uh the
idea of
providing kind of a monthly universal
payment to
families with children has been uh going
on in european countries for decades
and it's shown that that's really really
effective in terms of reducing the rate
of childhood poverty
and uh in the uh in president biden's um
pandemic package we have a
version of that where you know every
family with a child would get three or
four hundred dollars a month
um so we we are actually starting to get
some research in
on the effect of this type of a of a
policy there's a there was a study that
just came out from stockton california
that did kind of a universal basic
income and they actually showed it had
really
positive effects and interestingly
it actually the folks that were getting
the ubi actually had
higher rates of employment than those
who weren't
because that's one of the fears that you
know this creates a work disincentive
actually it creates a lot of positive
incentives in terms of people you know
being able to live what i often refer to
as a livable life
the mobility question is an interesting
one where there's a bunch of ways to
measure
how likely it is that if born into
poverty one will exit poverty and you
can look at this at a country level you
can
parse it out by education and race and
all of these different things
for those who are born into poverty
but get out of it what do we know about
the following generation the kids of
those folks
and their likelihood of remaining out of
poverty as well
yeah so the way i like to think about
this is that
it's the notion of cumulative inequality
so first of all as i said most folks who
experience poverty do so
fairly short periods of time but they
may not get that far above the poverty
line yeah
um but the way the way we we often like
to think about the united states is that
there's a level playing field and you
know everybody's kind of starting at the
same point
and i use the analogy in the book of
actually what's going on
is a um modified game of monopoly
oh this is interesting now i i've used
this and
i think i've used this analogy before
and i'm wondering where you first heard
it actually
well i i thought i came up with it but
oh did you oh that's interesting
wow but i i don't know we'll tell it to
us because let's see if it's the same
one i use yeah
okay so you know we we normally think
about a game of monopoly
we have three players everybody starts
out with fifteen hundred dollars
they go around the rules of the game
apply and you know
luck and chance and skill um uh
determine who is going to win the game
but now let's look at an altered game of
monopoly where player one starts out
with five thousand dollars
player two starts out with the fifteen
hundred dollars and player three starts
out with two hundred fifty dollars
and we're still going to have the same
rules uh
and and and abide by those but
who's going to win most of those games
well given
the prior advantages player one
is going to win considerably more even
if he or she is not as lucky or as
skilled
okay um and the other point is that
player one can play the game
differently than player three they can
take more
chances if player three makes one
mistake it's over
and and that's what's really going on in
this country is we have an
altered game of monopoly where some
players are starting out with that five
thousand dollars
more and more players are starting out
with maybe a thousand or fifteen hundred
and uh unfortunately many people are
starting out with the 250
so we really we need to think about how
can we
address some of these prior advantages
and disadvantages
so that we have more of a sense of the
quality of opportunity which we often
talk about as important in the united
states
right so we're at the end of our time
but so my version of the analogy is
yeah it's almost the same it's everybody
really does get the same amount of cash
but the late starting players have to
contend with all the properties already
having hotels on them
absolutely and so but it's it's really
the same idea that's very interesting
yeah yeah no that that is we've been
speaking with mark robert rank professor
of social welfare
at washington university in st louis the
book is poorly understood which we will
link to
um in the youtube video for for our
conversation today
mark really a pleasure having you on oh
this was great david i really enjoyed it